doris duke was tall blonde
beautiful and rich a tabloid staple
the mid-20th century wasn't the viral
celebrity sex
tape world we live in now but the press
was still incredibly invasive
so when news broke that doris this
famous socialite from one of america's
richest families
might have intentionally killed her best
friend the public geared up for the
trial of the century
justice would be swift for door as they
thought but they would be wrong
i first started looking into the doris
duke car crash
last year a little over five decades
since the incident occurred
i grew up in new jersey not far from one
of doris duke's estates so i was pretty
familiar with her
doris duke is known for her philanthropy
she's given a lot of money away to
charity
she's all these foundations in her name
but there's all this mystery around her
she was so much of a recluse and she
relied to privacy so people are always
drawn to her and to know more because
she was so tucked away from society in a
way she was a reluctant public figure
who did not like to be in the limelight
but again she was drawn into the
limelight because
at the time she was one of the richest
women in the world
newport was a summer playground for the
wealthy
duke loved the peace and privacy and it
wasn't surprising that she enjoyed
october's there when the summer homes
were left vacant
as tourists returned to the city
she lived somewhat anonymously tucked
away in her property as she liked
she spent years there before the
accident which wouldn't happen until she
turned 53
she was settled down as much as a person
of her celebrity could be
doris duke and edward tarella knew each
other for a good decade
they're pretty close companions they
confide in each other
eduardo torella was a new jersey native
he was famous in his own right he was an
interior designer as well
as a movie set designer ed water was
also
her artistic curator and he helped
design her homes
on her many estates so she trusted him
and really sought his advice when
designing
her homes
[Music]
according to an article in vanity fair
eduardo was planning to give his notice
that he was going to cut personal and
professional ties with doris
and head out west to california he
wanted to get his career in the film
industry off the ground
and felt that duke was stifling it if he
was going to stay with her
he was never going to make it big
eduardo told his partner
as well as friends and family that he
was going to cut ties with doris duke
and they warned him about this they said
it would anger her
and that it wouldn't end well but he
wanted to tell her in person
and that's why he was with her the day
the accident happened
that night doris wanted eduardo to drive
her to an appointment
they got in the car ready to go eduardo
was in the driver's seat but he had to
get out to go open the gate to get onto
bellevue avenue so he put the car in
park and he got out and door slid over
into the driver's seat
she claims that this car suddenly let
forward she doesn't know what happened
and at some point eduardo was pinned
against the gate
and the car crashed straight through the
gate and into a tree on bellevue avenue
[Music]
doris was found in a fog wandering
around she was bleeding from head wounds
and she didn't know what happened and
had water was found under the back of
the car crushed
he had died instantly police did not
question duke for two days after the
accident occurred
why did officials wait 48 hours to
question the only witness of eduardo
torrella's last moments
reporters were stationed around her
gates trying to get access to anyone who
worked for her
but it was under investigation and the
police weren't talking
not even a little over a week after this
incident occurred
she was donating money left and right
she gave 25 000
to restore a historic cliff walk in
newport
then soon after she gave 10 grand to
newport hospital
which is where she had been staying
after the incident and
a few months later following these
donations she had set up the newport
restoration fund
which was meant to restore 84 colonial
arab buildings
in newport a lot of people believe she
bought her way out of this that she paid
blood money
to make this go under the rug and just
forget about it to get her out of the
limelight and that
pretend this never happened a lot of the
evidence
seems like it was mislabeled or it just
mysteriously vanished
even court cases her statements so it
seems like
whether there was a cover-up or the
police didn't do their job
there was a lack of accountability at
the time and that's what makes it so
much harder to dive into this case and
find out what truly happened
the official conclusion of the
investigation was that terrella's death
was not intentional
rather it was just an unfortunate
accident
but the tarellas maintained that doris
duke intentionally and deliberately ran
over eduardo
they filed a suit against her in 1967
seeking 1.25 million dollars
for years the case dragged on and five
years after the incident
doris duke was found guilty of
negligence and ordered to pay the family
000 the fact that ed water was
such her close friend why wouldn't she
want to help them out and
be there for them at this time she
caused the death of her friend
the story of the car crash incident
pretty much was a blood stain on doris
duke's legacy
while she did a lot of great
philanthropy and she donated a lot of
money
and she really did help people this just
couldn't go away this was on her record
forever
people couldn't stop talking about it
and while she was a recluse
early on and into her later years
especially you know people were so
curious
what really did happen well the only
person who actually knows what happened
is doris duke and she took that secret
right to her grave
[Music]